well first up our story today it's gonna
be wedding bells for machine gun kelly
and megan fox yes but we got details on
that ring
and i liked finding out what they were
people reports that machine gun kelly
designed it himself he also designed it
with thorn tips so that if megan tries
to take it off it hurts a little bit
okay well that feels very in keeping
with them a little torture a little
[Music]
the ring is actually two rings one
emerald for her birthstone
one diamond for his another detail i
liked knowing and then the two are
attracted to each other by a magnet that
snaps them together what's this couple
gonna do next rossi i'm here for this uh
you know i'm here for it too i'm glad
they found each other because
they said after they got engaged they
drank each other's blood yeah i'm cute
okay and then
um
which again i couldn't tell if they were
being jokey or serious i never know but
i'm here for all of it i'm here for it
but i don't know about a thorn that
hurts when you take it off i like i like
to kick it old school and just not to be
able to take it off when i eat too much
bacon you know what i mean like that's
the way it should be well that's why
there's s and m
unless s m and more eminem
that's kind of how i roll
but i'm glad i really am glad that they
found each other
next up we've got some news on one of my
favorite bodily functions
it's laughter
i love this story so
ready for it upward reports scientists
have actually discovered at least 65
different species of animals they love a
good laugh too gorillas chimpanzees
seals dogs cows rats they all get the
giggles and right can you imagine how
cute like
just picture like a fox giggling can you
even picture it well guess what we have
video of fox's giggling look at this
[Applause]
okay
i'm sorry
is that not
and this is the kind of news i need in
my day i need to see that fox i didn't
even know that animals really could
laugh you know how i try to like make
jokes to my chihuahuas they won't even
throw me a bone nothing
but now i can't stop thinking about
animals i want to see laugh like don't
you want to see a dolphin giggle i feel
like that's what they're doing
that's right
you know what i didn't know you could do
a dolphin zone i do like to i i do
dolphin what other animals can you do i
don't know test me okay do a horse
okay throwing at me looks good horsey
your horse
my horse is gay
[Applause]
but i will be channeling the visual of
that fox for the rest of my life like
that is goals right there well next up i
asked the news division i said listen we
have got to get some information on why
this phenomenon is taking place why
two days ago did i not know about wordle
and now i can't open a cupboard without
wordle popping out can i tell you this
morning welly said we've got to play
wordle i had never heard about until
this morning and now we're talking about
it everyone is i'm like origin story
okay because if you're not already on
the world train and i know it just
sounds like a word that's like nonsense
but listen to this it's not nonsense the
new york times reports that wordle is
the daily word game on your phone that's
become an absolute viral runaway hit not
to be mistaken by an app it's only a
link right now but wait to see what's
coming with this it was created last
fall by a software engineer named josh
wardall
and it was a sweet gift for his partner
because she loved word games and she
loved it so much josh ended up sharing
it with the world and on november 1st 90
people played and today
over 2.5 million people play worldwide
and it's growing bigger and bigger by
the hour not just the day why the wordle
fever it's fun it's quick it's free it's
new every day it gives you a tiny win
and it's shareable players are sharing
cute little emoji boards to show their
scores every day
rossi well i love this because you can
actually only play it once a day
[Music]